madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
lionel jospin en déplacement dans le
morbihan promet 100 % des indemnisations
pour les victimes de la marée noire de
quoi rassurer les associations qui
n'avaient obtenu qu'une partie des
remboursements aux états unis l'essai du
bouclier anti missile testé la nuit
dernière a été un nouvel échec que ce
dispositif contesté par les russes et
les chinois fait craindre une nouvelle
course aux armements
le festival solidays à l'hippodrome de
longchamp 80000 spectateurs attendus
pour cette manifestation de solidarité
en faveur des malades du sida au
rendez-vous 200 musiciens pour une
quarantaine de concerts le début de
collection haute couture automne hiver
2000 avec l'extravagant john galliano
pour la maison dior étonnant surprenant
le talent totalement débridée du
styliste britannique pare chocs contre
pare chocs mais avec le soleil pour
complice les départs sur la route des
vacances bison futé avait vu juste il
avait vu rouge pour cette journée de
samedi et les bouchons furent bien au
rendez vous dans la vallée rhône-alpes
ces dernières heures la circulation
dense améliorant un dernier point avec
virginie fichés et les échecs là une
pointe de ciel gris dont une journée
rouge
et comme par magie le trafic s'éclaircit
pour circuler c'est la condition idéale
on n'a pas d'accident on n'a pas
d'éclatement de pneumatiques on n'a pas
de véhicule en panne moteur qui
chauffent quand un tas d'éléments qui
font que
eh ben les gens circulent et ne s'arrête
pas parce que ils sont passés de partir
haussier qui n'occasionne pas de bouchon
est donc sage en calcium la clémence du
ciel n'a pas tout empêcher au plus fort
de la matinée sur l'autoroute a7 les
automobilistes ont rencontré jusqu'à 30
km de ralentissement entre valence et
montélimar
plus au nord
le passage de l'agglomération lyonnaise
a lui aussi laissé quelques traces lyon
et à la plaque ii
vacant bonjour bougeront bouche en
bouche on est à présent crevaison
certains ont joué de malchance pendant
que d'autres récolter les fruits de leur
patience les plus pressés s'était jeté
dans le flou autoroutier dès hier soir
conséquence pour les retardataires la
voie était presque libre a été bloqué
par heure un quart d'heure vingt minutes
à tout casser
sinon ça roule bien impeccable oh ça va
s'arranger
nous étions bien loin aujourd'hui des
bouchons historiques qui ont fait la
renommée de cette vallée du rhône
pourtant depuis ce matin entre 2 158
véhicules tout de même ont emprunté
l'autoroute a7
demain dimanche est classé vert et son
retour du soleil on pense déjà au
prochain week-end de grands départs et
on espère qu'ils seront aussi calment
les nouvelles recommandations de
prudence pour ceux qui doivent prendre
le volant depuis hier la mobilisation
des gendarmes sur les routes de france
avec notamment ses opérations de
contrôle de vitesse d'un genre nouveau
sur la nationale 13 des voitures
banalisées se fondent dans la
circulation pour constater les
infractions ce dispositif beaucoup moins
voyant que les traditionnels contrôles
se déroulaient notamment dans leur
département particulièrement touché
frédéric vian didier morel
cette voiture est un véhicule de
gendarmerie elle n'en a pas l'air et
c'est justement le but recherché il
s'agit de traquer les mauvais
conducteurs au coeur même de la
circulation
là où radars et barrages sont
inefficaces la voiture banalisée
c'est l'armé absolue
en limite
par exemple cette voiture grise devant
nous roulent à 150 km heure les deux
gendarmes arrivent à peine à la suivre
l'infraction est manifeste
prévenu par radio une autre équipe de
gendarmes se postent en embuscade
quelques kilomètres plus loin les
conditions atmosphériques 1
vous avez commencé services et puis ça
se finir 150
le chauffard est arrêté mais ils
protestent pour lui le procédé n'est pas
fiable
il est pourtant parfaitement légale
c'est que pour les vitesses vraiment
élevé l'usagé de route peut être
verbalisé au simple vu de la vitesse au
suivi du véhicule ce motard en revanche
ne contestera pas il a franchi la ligne
blanche il le reconnaît mais il doute
que la mesure soit pédagogique je pense
que lyon devra lire pleurer plus
facilement parce que c'est plus de la
prévention que la répression chose je
veux dire dans un kilomètre jeu sûrement
refermer une chose la prévention c'est
pourtant justement le but recherché par
les pouvoirs publics
je crois qu'il est indispensable que
chaque cas ce disque à tout moment dans
tout lieu
cl comme une infraction il peut être
verbalisés et à l'évidence il faut pas
informé chacun de l'endroit où se
trouvent les forces de l'ordre avec les
voitures banalisées la sécurité routière
cherche à rendre permanente la peur du
gendarme
une peur hélas nécessaire pour inciter
les conducteurs à la prudence
lionel j'espère en déplacement dans le
morbihan promet 100 % d'indemnisation à
toutes les victimes de l'erika de quoi à
tranquilliser les collectifs anti marée
noire inquiet des remboursements est
suffisante du fipol le premier ministre
sur les plages de l'atlantique venait
également en touriste d'encourager
d'autres que lui à passer leurs vacances
d'été dans la région arnaud bouté à la
location
pour observer l'opération de pompage de
l'erika lunel jospin choisi la voie des
airs
pas de visite sur le chantier le premier
ministre préfère admirer la
transformation du rivage
six mois après la catastrophe le sable
ressemble à du sable lionel jospin veut
rassurer les touristes effrayés par la
marée dont les plages ont rouvert mais
les professionnels du tourisme et des
politiques s'inquiètent alors ils le
font savoir
les touristes ne sont pas au rendez vous
et donc le préjudice sera sans doute
assez assez significatif et à la
question qui doit payer les habitants de
ploemeur vise directement le pollueur
ils demandent au premier ministre
d'intervenir j'espère que il va pousser
un peu les pollueurs à régler les
communs qu'ils ont fait quoi que c'est
les laisons de total fina pire accros
qui paieront en guise de réponse
lionel jospin promet d'indemniser toutes
les victimes de la marée noire
l'état paiera donc mais également total
fina
ce sera une indemnisation à 100% des
dégâts
tbl établi qu'ils auront été
effectivement mais mesurée et donc
l'état avec les partenaires
et donc éventuellement cette entreprise
aura un dédié qu'il en soit ainsi c'est
l'engagement que je confiant avec la
france présidente de l'union européenne
une à jospin soit aussi lancé un appel à
ses partenaires
objectif renforcer la sécurité et les
contrôles du transport maritime et
tenter de préserver seul
au-delà des questions de pollution
lionel je sais pas a tenu à commenter
lui même l'annoncé d'un prochain
référendum sur le quinquennat
c'est la voie qu'a choisie jacques
chirac pour modifier la durée du mandat
présidentiel
je vous propose d'écouter l'appel louis
du premier ministre j'ai vu de cette
idée du quinquennat ramener comme elle
était la mienne je les appuyer je
constate maintenant que le président est
d'accord
et sur la proposition que je lui a faite
conformément à la constitution
hui a pris l'initiative de proposer un
référendum
naturellement j'appellerai pour le mois
de septembre à voter oui à ce référendum
parce que je pense que passer au
quinquennat c'est à dire offrir aux
français tous les cinq ans la
possibilité de décider dans une élection
important l'élection présidentielle est
un progrès démocratique
les démocraties doivent vivent à un bris
suffisamment rapide et lorsque l'on
interroge l'opinion publique sur le
quinquennat à travers ce sondage csa
pour le parisien 58% des français se
disent prêtes à s'abstenir de voter lors
du référendum du 24 septembre prochain
même si 88 % sont pour
si l'on compare ce chiffre à d'autres
sondages prêtent en mai juin dernier le
pourcentage des personnes interrogées
favorables au quinquennat est en
progression constante et le taux
d'abstention suit la même courbe
les victimes de l'amiante de la faculté
de jussieu attendait beaucoup de cette
journée d'hier mais la commission
d'indemnisation a rapporté a reporté sa
décision sans donner de nouveau
calendrier il est simplement question
d'attendre la fin de l'instruction et
ceux ci pourraient prendre des mois
voire encore des années la colère et
l'exaspération de l'association
nationale de défense des victimes qui
parle ouvertement d'un jugement
politique
hélène vergne michel levasseur il faut
pas faire de vagues
ce que tout soit coupée pour que les
gens sachent minimum de choses
continuent de faire ce qu'il veut les
mots n'étaient pas assez forts pour
exprimer leur colère leur écoeurement
toutes atteintes d'infections
pulmonaires dus à l'amiante
les victimes de jussieu demander
réparation du préjudice subi
la commission d'indemnisation a préféré
reporter sa décision
en attendant dit elle que soit
déterminer les responsabilités de la
contamination à jussieu mais
l'instruction engagé il ya quatre ans
n'a pas avancé d'un pouce
c'est à dire d'un côté on dit que les
victimes wotan doit être indemnisée et
puis de l'autre côté évidemment on fait
tout pour qu'elle ne le soit pas mais
aussi on cherche à l'évidence sur un
dossier qui met en cause des
responsabilités ministérielles
parce que a essayé d'étouffer ce ce
dossier et ça c'est vraiment scandaleux
d'autant plus scandaleux pour les
victimes que les dangers de l'amiante
sont connus depuis longtemps
c'est à jussieu qu'on a donné l alerte
pour la première fois en 1975
sans résultat depuis les travaux de
déflocage ont à peine commencé
les victimes ils sont de plus en plus
nombreuses une soixantaine aujourd'hui
parmi elles d'anciens mécanicien mais
aussi des maîtres de conférences
tous sont aujourd'hui malades ça peut
atteindre n'importe où n'importe où
n'importe qui et je suis par me demander
si les étudiants qui viennent passer
trois quatre ans ici peut-être plus
maintenant parce que quelques travaux
ont été faits mais avant noms n'ont pas
été aussi qu'on aime le contaminer si
c'est le cas il faudra certainement
plusieurs dizaines d'années pour le dire
et déterminer réellement l'ampleur de la
catastrophe sanitaire qui touche jussieu
au chapitre social le cas de l'usiné
dunlop pourrait devenir une nouvelle
affaire michelin montluçon dans l'allier
plusieurs centaines de personnes
manifestaient cet après midi pour
protester contre la suppression de 400
emplois à l'usiné dunlop de la ville
toutes tendances confondues de nombreux
élus faisait partie du cortège
bien décidé à se battre pour que la
réorganisation de l'entreprise
une première fois rachetée par un
japonais qui l'an passé s'était associé
à l'américain goodyear ne menace pas les
emplois de la région
marie-pierre samitier olivier
aujourd'hui
dès 15h30 ils sont arrivés par petits
groupes pour dire non au plan de
réorganisation de dunlop non à la
suppression de plus de 400 emplois la
plupart étaient des ouvriers de l'usiné
mais il y avait aussi des morceaux n'est
venu par solidarité
personne ne va fermer une autre ailleurs
alors si ce n'est cet effet dans une
usine normalement devaient 83 redémarre
bien je ne paie pas les missiles
car depuis peu l'usiné dunlop et
d'équipés d'un atelier pneus poids
lourds très performant un atelier en
partie financé par des fonds publics
et c'est justement la fabrication des
pneus poids lourds que dans l'ope veut
transférer au luxembourg et en allemagne
de la colère des syndicats et des élus
qui dénoncent les bénéfices de la
multinationale dunlop vous dire j'ai
sorti leurs bénéfices
plusieurs milliards de dollars j'ai
sorti qu'ils avaient déjà ici supprimer
51 emplois qui avait qui leur avait
apporté 384 millions de francs les
restructurations qui suppriment des
emplois rapporte de l'argent aux grandes
entreprises une pétition signée par 120
élus se dresse au parlement européen
pour qu'on trouve une solution
européenne et s'adresse postiers au
gouvernement de lionel jospin
on fera appel au gouvernement on va
demander à rencontrer le gouvernement
que ce soit le problème les shows à
l'autre de manière à ce qu'ils prennent
leurs responsabilités
oubliée chez dunlop depuis neuf ans
alain et veto vient de s'endetter pour
sa maison
pour lui l'avenir est incertain voilà
rentré je peux amener à teaser
franchir la ligne voilà vous inquiète
oui femme inquiète pour moi puis pour ma
famille surtout mes enfants ma femme du
travailleur dans le fond alors nombreux
seront ceux qui refuseront une offre de
reclassement dans une autre région
autant de futurs chômeurs dans une ville
déjà sinistré par le chômage est encore
un nouveau cas de vache folle une année
noire pour la france cette fois ci pour
la première fois le cas d'un animal
touché par l'encéphalopathie spongiforme
bovine a été décelée dans l'isère le
troupeau a été abattu ce matin
au total depuis le mois de janvier 24
vaches se sont révélés atteintes par la
maladie
pour lutter contre le temps qui passe la
mobilisation en faveur des otages aux
philippines prend différentes formes
pétition site internet et puis ce matin
à strasbourg
l'école nationale supérieure des arts et
industries a dédié sa cérémonie de
remise des diplômes à stepan loisy et
sonia vending tous les deux anciens
élèves de l'établissement
reportage christine beauce patrick
schumacher à l'école nationale
supérieure des arts et industries de
strasbourg on battait le rappel ce matin
en faveur de deux anciens élèves et du
coup la traditionnelle les très
officiels cérémonie de remise de
diplômes et est empreinte d'une gravité
inhabituelle
je souhaite placer cette remise de
diplômes sous le signe de la solidarité
envers deux diplômés de l'école qui est
elle ici à votre place il ya onze ans je
veux parler de sonja van ligne et
stéphanoises y encore otage aujourd'hui
aux philippines et qui ont erré tous les
deux diplômés de la filière génie
mécanique
en juillet 1989 depuis plusieurs
semaines l'école d'ingénieurs se
mobilisent en faveur du sort des otages
par la voie hiérarchique en alertant les
sommet de l'état aujourd'hui elle
exprimé sa solidarité aux familles
venues témoigner de leur détresse dans
leur courrier reviennent souvent la même
phrase la même demande
sortez nous d'ici que répondre à cela
nous essayons de les soutenir lui mieux
que nous pouvons mais nous restons
impuissance impuissant et cette
impuissance est insupportable mes
parents et moi même avons fait un choix
buts et lutter contre quoi l'oubli ces
étudiants n'ont évidemment pas connu
sagna et stéphane mais grâce au réseau
très efficace des anciens de l'école de
sites internet ont vu le jour pour
informer et communiquer sans relâche ces
messages sont régulièrement envoyés au
ministère des affaires étrangères pour
que biya la valise diplomatique qu'ils
arrivent sur place
chez sonia et stéphane afin qu'ils
sachent que la mobilisation est forte
ici en france et que nous les soutenons
de tout coeur pour qu'ils gardent le
moral
sonia stéphane et les 18 autres otages
entameront demain leur 80e jours de
détention
le jeune alexis condamné à 82 présent
pour le sextuple meurtre de look sienne
ou celle sa demi soeur âgée de 3 ans
avait été épargné
alexis a été libéré ce matin aujourd'hui
âgé de 22 ans le jeune homme compte
s'installer en france la conférence
internationale sur le sida pour la
première fois se tiendra en afrique sur
ce continent dévasté par la maladie ces
deux mâts d'urban sur la côte est que
spécialistes et scientifiques se
retrouveront pour faire le point sur
l'épidémie qui touche un adulte sur
trois sur le continent noir
dans ce pays où en moins de 20 ans le
sida considérablement réduit l'espérance
de vie de toute une population
l'exemple du cameroun qui manque
cruellement là aussi de moyens pour
aider ou soigner les patients
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
patrick fandio que frédéric basket
des cicatrices des séquelles d'un
terrible zone à cette affection courante
chez des patientes comme suzanne
infectées par le vih aujourd'hui elle
vient chercher des antibiotiques
demander conseil trouver du réconfort
elle sait que c'est tout ce qu'on peut
lui offrir ici et qu'il faudrait presque
un miracle pour qu'elles aient accès un
jour à la trithérapie mais idée l'un de
ses enfants et lui aussi séropositifs
des cas comme celui là on en recense
plusieurs dizaines par semaine dans ce
centre d aide aux malades
le nombre de personnes infectées a
doublé en un an des grands mères des
jeux des bébés accueillis par des
infirmières débordé et démunis
on les assiste et on laissa mais les
soins que nous faisons ici c'est des
soins palliatifs on n'a pas de moyens de
procurer la trithérapie à nos malades
ont beau je sais pas si on avait
possibilité mais ils sont au moins de
six ans qui viennent me voir
régulièrement le centre est gérée par un
réseau de femmes africaines elle
aimerait bien y faire du dépistage
gratuit car le coût d'un test ici et
dissuasif 80 francs mais la ration
alimentaire mensuelle d'une famille
moyenne d'après le sang nous avions
quand même des possibilités de faire des
tests gratuits aux personnes
complètement démuni je pense que ça
pourrait nous aider énormément le reflet
que nous avons à l'hôpital nous pousse à
penser que les chiffres officiels sont
peut-être en deçà de ce que vous voyons
réellement sur le terrain
et même si l'association française
ensemble contre le sida finance une
partie du centre l'équipe médicale
trouvent les bailleurs de fond trop peu
généreux face à l'hécatombe qui
s'annonce aux etats unis le projet de
bouclier anti missile testé la nuit
dernière a essuyé un nouvel échec
un essai qui pourra peut-être signer
l'abandon de ce dispositif antimissile
largement dénoncée par les russes et les
chinois
au delà de la simple déception des
militaires américains et du chef de la
maison blanche
voilà posé une nouvelle fois la question
de la course aux armements qui
préoccupent les européens correspondance
dominique derda edouard perrin on allait
voir ce qu'on allait voir
après un premier test réussi en octobre
dernier à ce plan créé le 18 janvier
ce troisième essai l'interception d'un
missile balistique était celui qu'il ne
fallait surtout pas rater
du moins pour les partisans de ce
système de défense passons guerre des
étoiles cher jadis à l'ancien président
ronald reagan
dans un monde où malheureusement
prolifèrent toutes sortes domicile si
nous ne disposons d'aucun moyen de nous
en protéger alors nous jouons avec le
feu
les militants de greenpeace sont
ressortis pour l'occasion zodiac et
banderoles ils protestent contre ce
qu'ils considèrent comme une relance de
la course aux armements et ils ne sont
pas les seuls 50 prix nobel ont adressé
à bill clinton une lettre dans laquelle
il le conjure de renoncer à ce projet
coûteux et inefficace autant dire qu'au
pentagone en suit avec inquiétude le
déroulement de l'opération
le missile tiré dans le ciel de
californie célèbres comme prévu mais son
intercepteurs partie 20 minutes plus
tard dans le pacifique n'atteindra
jamais cessé consternation dans la salle
de contrôle sur le film d'animation
pourtant tout paraissait réglé comme du
papier à musique
l'intercepteur devait bien faire la
différence entre les leurs et la tête du
mi6 c'est à voir celle du général
kaddish on imagine sa déception les
explications sont encore confuses
c'est la pile d'un télémètre qui aurait
parait-il mal fonctionné pour les
ingénieurs et les militaires qui ont
travaillé sur ce programme
retour à la case départ pour bill
clinton annonce de ce nouvel échec et
paradoxalement plutôt une bonne nouvelle
il n'est pas fâché dit on à washington
de laisser à son successeur à la maison
blanche le soin de décider de la
poursuite ou non de ce projet très
controversé tant aux états unis qu'à
l'étranger à rome malgré l'hostilité du
vatican et de l'extrême droite la gay
pride a finalement réussi à s'imposer
des milliers d'homosexuels dans une
ambiance bonne enfant rejoint le colisée
une immense fête avec pour enjeu lutter
contre les discriminations
correspondance isabelle steiss de nick
mal
image sans précédent à rome transsexuels
homosexuels lesbiennes qui paradent par
milliers dans les rues de la capitale
italienne
et c'est comme une révolution qui
s'accomplit ici à proximité du siège de
la papauté inité égalité fraternité et
sexuelle et grâce à jean paul ii nous
avons une publicité énorme le remercier
c'est une grande victoire après cette
journée puis personnes en italie ne
pourra dire que les homosexuels n'ont
pas le soutien de la majorité de la
population pour la cerner car après des
mois de confrontation avec le vatican
la gay pride 2000 a finalement gagné le
droit de défiler en pleine année sainte
pas maintenant pas à rome n'avait cessé
de marteler le vatican jugeant la
manifestation blasphématoire
le pape doit voir que nous aussi
croyance en dieu nos systèmes religieux
et le pape a rien dit il s'est excusé
sur un certain nombre de choses par
rapport à l'église
est ce parce que l'église a fait travers
mais jamais un mot pour les gays du
monde en symbole d'une italie qui
aujourd'hui plus que jamais cherché à se
libérer du poids de l'église
certains sont venus avec la mama je suis
transsexuel elle est d'accord avec la
sexualité
et même au sein de l'église aujourd'hui
des voix se sont publiquement élevé
contre la position du vatican
couzier demandé passons et aux
lesbiennes pour tout le mal que l'église
catholique
les organisateurs de la gay pride 2011
ont gagné la bataille de roms car
l'hostilité du vatican et la frilosité
des autorités politiques auront
finalement eu pour conséquence d'ouvrir
le débat sur l'homosexualité en italie
et au sein même de l'église catholique
demain jean paul ii célébrera la messe
du jubilé des prisons l'occasion pour le
saint père de rendre hommage aux
aumôniers des centres pénitenciers un
thème qui s'inscrit largement dans
l'actualité avec le rapport des
parlementaires publié ces jours-ci sur
la vétusté l'état désastreux du système
carcéral en france un système on le
retrouve pourtant des hommes de bonne
volonté comme le montre ce reportage de
marc maisonneuve et cédric picot qui ont
suivi le moigne et de la prison de melun
en seine-et-marne
le rituel est immuable pour entrer en
prison
l'abbé colliard est accompagné du
gardien chef ensuite il est libre de ses
mouvements et ici c'est bien le seul
car lui possède les clefs de sa cellule
c'est l'aumônerie de la prison de melun
où vivent trois cent douze détenus
condamnés pour la plupart à de très
longues peines
prêtre depuis 40 ans la d'écolière
accueille tout le monde sans exception
je suis pas là pour faire un deuxième
jugement a ajouté le bois qui zoo qui
peuvent porter sur les actes qu'ils ont
commis
la chapelle dans l'enceinte même de la
prison elle n'est pas très fréquenté
seulement le samedi à 17h pour une
unique mais ce qui dépasse rarement 30
minutes ici on ne prie pas devant les
autres j'aurais posé la question
si priaient c'est un gars de 21 ans et
des mots dits oui c'est à dire cette
dimension spirituelle effet présence de
dieu existe je dirais un puisant
peut-être plus qu'ailleurs
seuls face à leur conscience les détenus
pris dans leurs cellules des cellules
individuelles melun est la seule prison
d'île de france où c'est le cas grâce à
l'aumônerie en 10 ans et 5 mois
eric a eu le temps de prier après ces
crimes et sa psychothérapie tout est
pardonné
c'est que tout devient le notre père en
disant on demande à dieu de pardonner
nos en france ce ne sont pas chacun
individuellement capable de parler son
prochain quoi tu les fais et ça le pas
non c'est déjà un acte d'amour lui n'est
pas là pour pardonner
pierre morin et gardiens de prison
depuis 26 ans pour le chef morin
l'aumônier un rôle clé il introduit
notion rare en prison
la notion d'humanité il est là aussi
pour la religion mais je pense qu'il fut
surtout de l'humanité parce qu'il ya des
détenus qui défendent et ont des
problèmes graves des problèmes familiaux
et il est là pour les aider
des fois à passer des caps difficiles le
père collier raid les détenus leurs
familles mais aussi les familles de
victimes intermédiaire catholique il a
selon son église le pouvoir et le devoir
de pardonner au nom de dieu
pourtant selon lui l'essentiel du chemin
et le travail du détenu le pardon du
prêtre est sèche dirait le site certifié
d'un pardon réel mais si avoriaz rien
c'est comme si on faisait une piqûre sur
une jambe de bois pour le perco lierre
racheter ses fautes c'est d'abord
apprendre à vivre avec le poids de la
culpabilité la canicule en europe et en
particulier dans les îles grecques avec
ces incendies qui touchent l'île de
samos des flammes poussées par la force
des vents compliquent la tâche des
pompiers commentaires gilles marie mai
c'est tout le sud de l'île qui est
menacée le feu qui a dévoré un millier
d'hectares de forêts et de cultures
cerner aujourd'hui plusieurs villages 30
maisons ont brûlé dans l'une d'elles on
retrouvera le corps carbonisé d'une
femme de 92 ans évacué en compagnie
d'autres personnes âgées elle était
revenu seul sur les lieux la plupart des
habitants sont restés sur place pour
aider les 500 pompiers débordés depuis
jeudi par un sinistre qui bénéficie d'un
vent fort et capricieux ainsi que d'une
sécheresse exceptionnelle c'est comme si
la végétation étaient gorgées d'essence
a déclaré l'un des responsables de lille
les avions les hélicoptères bombardiers
d'eau n'ont pas pu empêcher la formation
d'un rideau de flammes long de plusieurs
kilomètres
les pompiers qui ont réussi jusqu'à
présent à maintenir le feu en lisière
des agglomérations attendent le renfort
de centaines de militaires il espère
surtout que le vent se décide enfin à
tomber en france plusieurs départs de
feu dans le sud est autour de l'étang de
berre dans les bouches du rhône 250
pompiers à pied d'oeuvre contre un
incendie qui prend de l'ampleur on
apprend à l'instant d'ailleurs que deux
pompiers ont été tués dans cet incendie
la préfecture pour l'instant ne plus
dire les conditions exactes de ce drame
la préfecture qui a mis en place une
cellule de crise le préfet de la région
devraient d'ailleurs se rendre sur place
dans la soirée
par ailleurs en haute corse où on en a
dénombré 30 départs d'incendié l ouest
de bastia dans ces régions où le vent
est particulièrement fort les pompiers
sont en état d' alerte alors qu'en corse
du sud un incendie s'est approchée des
zones d'habitation sans pour autant de
nécessité leur évacuation
depuis quatre ans marie josé pérec eux
n'avait pas couru le 400 m à nice cet
après midi elle a pris la troisième
place en 50 secondes 32 centièmes lors
de cette épreuve déterminante dans sa
carrière à venir avec comme point
d'orgue les jeux olympiques de sydney
patrick montel
elle est au couloir numéro 4 marie josé
pérec donc que pour sa grande rentrée
sur le tour de piste pour son heure de
vérité voilà quatre ans que marie josé
pérec n'a pas couru en compétition
la dernière fois c'était à bruxelles en
1996 juste
après son titre olympique sa double
médaille d'or à atlanta c'est donc une
course extrêmement importante
marie jo pérec y aura devant elle la
jamaïcaine lauren graham sur laquelle
elle va essayer bien sûr de calquer sa
course et surtout attention à ce fameux
mur des 300 mètres sur lequel marie josé
pérec de toutes les luttes et bien sûr
marie josé pérec qui pour l'instant a
pris un très bon départ lauren graham au
couloir numéro 4 5 qui est juste devant
elle qui est partie également très très
vite par un josé pérec va certainement
essayer de calquer sa course sur celle
de g qui a pris maintenant aller cher
avantage la jamaïcaine qui est même
revenu sur son décalage sur la rue se
copiant va mais pour l'instant marie
josé pérec est toujours très très bien
très dans la nuit dans la région des
bibans va essayer de passer à la vitesse
supérieure c'est maintenant à ce moment
précis que ça serait bien difficile
parce que dans dans les jambes pour
marie jo qui va attaquer la dernière
ligne droite pour l'instant var et josé
pérec des toujours bien dans le times
c'est maintenant que ça va tenir dur
c'est pas ça qu'elle va tirer sur ses
vraies marie-josée black à la lutte avec
catherine déry et avec un horizon qui va
se battre jusqu'au bout qu'il va essayer
le meilleur chrono possible et je pense
à super chrono bernard puisque la venue
des 56 centièmes
ça va faire dans les 50 30 à vos besoins
le tour de france aujourd'hui la
huitième étape 203 kilomètres entre
limoges et villeneuve sur lot a été
remportée en solitaire par eric decker
le coureur de la rabobank a distancé ses
compagnons d'échappée à une trentaine de
kilomètres de l'arrivée
il s'est imposé avec 52 secondes
d'avancé sur le français le vainqueur
néerlandais s'est également emparé du
maillot à pois du meilleur grimpeur le
maillot jaune reste en revanche sur les
épaules de l'italien alberto elli pour
la deuxième journée consécutive
wimbledon la file and la finale dames
des internationaux de tennis cet
après-midi et l'américaine venus
williams tête de série numéro 5 a
remporté son premier titre du grand
chelem en s'imposant face à sa
compatriote de lindsay davenport
deuxième joueuse mondiale sur le score
de 6/3 7/6 commentaires nicolas le
mariner le clan williams voulait faire
de wimbledon une fête familiale
tous réunis derrière
venus numéro 5 mondial bien décidé à
prendre la place de la tenante du titre
lindsay davenport
dans le premier set venus respecte
l'objectif d'habitude plus à l'aise au
fond du court elle monte au filet prend
l'avantagé s'impose 6 jeux à 3 davenport
ressaisi au début du deuxième set mène 2
jeux à rien avant d'être rejointe au
score
elle tient tête jusqu'au jeu décisif
un jeu décisif que venus williams
remporte à l'issue d'une balle de match
et acculèrent à 20 ans la jeune
américaine gagne son premier tournoi du
grand chelem après le succès de serena à
l' us open 99
les williams ce sont les premières soeur
a décroché chacune un titre majeur
depuis le milieu de l'après midi le coup
d'envoi du festival solidays sur
l'hippodrome de longchamp 200 musiciens
pour une quarantaine de concerts et
80000 spectateurs attendus jusqu'à
demain soir pour marquer leur solidarité
avec les malades du sida
une solidarité à destination
essentiellement de l'afrique et de
l'asie dans les travées dès l'ouverture
quelques hommes politiques en campagne
au milieu d'une foule de jeunes dans une
ambiance très woodstock daniel wolfromm
mehdi diawara
sur la pelouse de l'hippodrome une
légende de la soul music américaine
depuis plus de 30 ans le groupe tnt
chaîne balladins si ces harmonies
vocales mais la solidarité contre le
sida n'attend pas le nombre des années
plus de 40 formations vont ainsi se
produire ce week-end comme l'an dernier
devant cette foule
la pluie fine lui donnent de faux airs
de woodstock
sur trois podiums les musiciens tourner
en alternance ici venus un groupe de
rock belge à la forte aspiration
britannique
mais personne sur cette pelouse n'oublie
la raison de sa venue pour oublier le
tiers-monde qui représente beaucoup plus
d'un tiers de malades par rapport à juin
par rapport à chez nous faut un accès
aux médicaments ça c'est le plus urgent
l'idée c'est qu'il ya la solidarité
c'est un mot qu un sens aujourd'hui si
on veut lui donner un sens le sens
premier en matière de sida c'est vers
l'afrique
les 34 millions de personnes qui sont
touchées là bas s'il n'y a pas des
mesures qui sont prises
je parle même pas d'années il avait dans
les mois qui viennent on va au devant
d'une catastrophe humanitaire sans
précédent
mais pour autant il ne faut pas négliger
la situation en france
je suis là pour rappeler ponctuellement
tous les ans avant les grandes vacances
et chaque fois qu'on me le demande qu'il
faut rester très vigilant ce qui
concerne la sida parce que la plupart
des gens pensent qu'avec la trithérapie
la bithérapie tout ça est réglé on peut
rentrer en cachette par jour et voilà
yuri buenaventura la salsa colombienne
ramène au concert l'an dernier plus de
80 mille jeunes avaient répondu à cette
manifestation de solidarité par l'
écoute de toutes les musiques
le début des collections haute couture
automne hiver 2000 à la maison dior a
donné les clés à l'extravagant john
galliano qui une fois encore séduit ou
surprend nicole cornu langlois bernard
connor
venez bonnes gens assister aux noces
flamboyante du spectacle de la haute
couture telles que les a conçus john
galliano pour dior
admirez cette précieuse robe
admirablement couper que tout marié
ambitieuse aimerait arborer le plus beau
jour de seine parmi les invités très
sophistiqué allure romantique europe
corsetée voici marisa berenson en
chapeau barry lyndon et dentelles
magique
le ton change ce point une liberté dont
les volants galonnés caches tu appelles
l'indécence puis le délire commence la
femme porte d'abord un chef-d'oeuvre du
groupe sculpté brodée de perles avant de
devenir sévère militaire j'était un
pervers
j'ai été inspiré par la correspondance
de freud ayew avant juste avant qu'il ne
rompent leurs relations
c'était sur le fétichisme des vêtements
et des chaussures qui est un thème
vraiment universel nous livre aussi des
fantasmes de son enfance ce qu'il
imaginait en regardant les adultes par
le trou de la sécu il reconstitue ainsi
en couture des jeux de cirque la
religion profané le théâtre chinois des
danses macquart et des rapports sado
masochistes
bravo monsieur galliano pour ce défilé
génial
et maintenant première et petites mains
à vos aiguilles à vos ciseaux pour que
des femmes
altière puisse porter ses extravagances
dans le monde entier
sans être ridicule
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les deux principaux titres
lionel jospin
en déplacement dans le morbihan promet
100 % d'adélie gestion pour les victimes
de la marée noire de quoi rassurer les
associations qui n'avaient obtenu qu'une
partie des remboursements
et puis cet incendie qui s'est déclaré
en fin d'après-midi dans les bouches du
rhône autour de l'étang de berre 250
pompiers sont à pied d'oeuvre
deux pompiers auraient été tués tout de
suite la météo présentée par laurent
romejko suivi de fort boyard avec
cendrine dominguez à 00h10 le dernier
journal olivier galzi de m'hamid y
jouent peu 10 aura pour thème l'afrique
du sud un reportage de richard binet
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver dès demain à 13h je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2